people right now listening to this I
want you to take a look around at
everybody you know that's married and
then I want you to count on you know
your fingers and toes how many of them
are actually happy the other thing that
I want you to take into consideration is
how many times have you heard them say
things like happy wife happy life or
she's my better half one of the most odd
behaviors that I see a lot of is around
birthdays and anniversaries and even
Valentine's Day which is my better half
she's the best person ever my best
friend blah blah blah blah and there's a
picture of him there with his family and
his kids and it's like you know like the
whole Hallmark card and then you click
hers and you look at what she's doing on
that day and it's crickets and there's a
picture of her on the beach with her
girlfriends drinking wine in their
bikinis right and it's like really do
you not see what's going on here my
friend you're the one doing all the work
you're the glue that's holding the
marriage together and she's showing
herself off to the world in a bikini
drinking wine with her girlfriends in
Cancun for the girls weekend